that's empowering for people especially
at the lower level when they don't know
what they're doing and sometimes that's
enough to get you hooked it's like you
do something cool you remember that kind
of stuff and it makes you want to learn
how to play the game
that's real rap i don't know how many
people in the chat if if that was your
situation where you fell in love with
tekken just by seeing cool moves by
mashing some buttons that that's i think
that's a byproduct of
excellent design at least at that level
right
of course a lot of you guys are here for
the competitive side of things and
that's obviously much different because
you look under a different microscope
but they wouldn't even be watching this
if they didn't think this stuff looked
cool you know like that you never know
first place sometimes you go on twitter
but they didn't
hear like oh you know this guy arsenash
uh he's a real good looking dude come
check him out competing you should like
throw him like that you know
i feel like they saw their thumbnail on
twitch and they saw your hair and
they're like you know what i'm in
i'm here what condition does that guy
use i'm watching competitive technique
what's his conditioner
here we go
oh he's gonna push towards the wall here
it's interesting that he picked kwarang
right yeah because i honestly thought
bang might have been maybe the better
choice here same
yeah but you know
i gotta say eddie is really good against
warren in my opinion why is that he has
a lot of just because there's certain
depending on how the huang plays if he
gets really really cheeky and tries to
go for certain mix-ups there's a lot of
options that eddie has where he can
evade whether it's down back on pursue
back one plus two or just ducking into
while setting one there's a lot of
damage there and also there's little
gaps where he can back three counter hit
i see
so eddie has a lot of opportunity
depending on how the huang plays
but that kind of goes into with eddie's
modus operandi is like you know he's
either gonna backdash or wait
defensively for his opportunity yep
here's the follow-up back two three
three
yeah i feel like fang's obviously strong
in this match let's see what he does he
goes for the mix-up
doesn't catch him
oh close it out nice nice clean up there
with the down four and this guy's first
of two games only first and two games
lose the semifinals low prairies are
good and as you can see this is the
weakness of droopy's horn right you'll
see a lot of his lows are really getting
him killed he doesn't have that problem
when he's fang though right it's his
down three fours and even like the scan
slows that get that like lost muscle or
what cost them but there we go mixing it
up with the mid this time
but weird combo ender choice there
doesn't matter he's got some damage
oh ceo
if he didn't have the power crest he
would have been launched
but again he has to be careful that
power push is not safe
yeah walls not broken behind count not a
lot of faithful counter-hit down forward
two will seal the first game from three
rounds straight
just the natural play style from callum
was just too much for
that character matchup and the way that
uh his opponent was approaching that
huang and droopy i didn't think would
have a good fit there just trying to
break down his opponent or take the
advantage over there i really think he
needs to switch to fenway to make this
work again because this is a shorter set
a race to two right
man maybe he should have started faying
from the get-go because i mean huarang
definitely did not work there was no
situation in that matchup where i saw he
had the advantage
at all right
and you know i saw the chat uh you know
talking about my criticism of his horror
i'm just saying that specifically the
match we've seen him lose with this
horrong right the way he has lost is
that the opponents have a good read on
his down three fours like that
specifically like we saw uh dvk
continuously duck and launched with
miguel and now we're seeing it look back
at this that he got low paired and
ducked a lot as well right so yeah uh
it's just that seems to be the weakness
of his horon specifically
so
now you know with his fang when we saw
that he didn't have that issue right um
we'll see what happens if he tries the
fang right here but i think he he might
stick it out with hora here i'm not sure
i'd switch i honestly i would switch i
feel like
he couldn't get any off and started and
if you're not doing that with huang
you're not doing anything
agreed
you didn't go for the pressure on too
right like he keeps you guessing
constantly
oh
he's sticking to it here we go he picks
brimstone and fire
all right all right
here we go sticking around here
he's gonna have to definitely mix things
up uh better right like and he's gotta
watch out for the loads like the dow b4
has definitely gotten killed in the last
set
definitely brimstone of fire
no transition infant stage which is kind
of a good thing for him here
all right i don't got to worry about
callum back dashing forever nice oh
there's a factory to start it off big
combo there peacekeeper in between the
follow up here he gets the wall mix up
see what he does
hey
nice good start doesn't get the launch
punish
that back to be not safe of course
launch punishable
another one nope too far
now what's he gonna do this is where
it's big
oh is he he's putting himself in
situations where he gets punished for
certain things
yep he has to make sure that he keeps
the pressure on but also stays safe
enough
yeah one of those characters that has
just you know a ton of options right so
you can you can often play them safer
but you got to take some risks at some
point
uh but choosing when to take the risk is
the question and there it is down before
it gets ducked and full launched
seems inevitable right oh yeah
that's for sure i mean there's a lot of
options that he has again but it's all
about how you approach the initial hit
and how you get into that up close game
nice
and again remember we were talking about
this before calum was not breaking
throws in any of the other matchups as
well so this might be an opportunity
maybe droopy
kind of realized here but it might be
too little too late he does have rage
this is going to hurt the drive nice
able to close it out
though finally getting around he needed
that definitely needed that let's go
ruby nice whip punch at the back three
four
oh and this is gonna hurt
what's the mix
he tried to back one plus two out of
there
again with the evasive attacks oh what
did he do he's trying to whip punish
with up to the people's four not gonna
happen and that's one of the moves yeah
you don't see enough
yeah the duck dude
oh caliber oh no don't let him come back
with this little help oh my gosh
airborne yep
yes man there was a low pair there that
would have been disaster but groupie got
at the leave now it's got to be building
a little bit of confidence nice oh that
a nice block punish i should say oh yeah
that is fast enough because that is what
negative 18.
here we go it does have a slight
pushback so sometimes punishers can be
inconsistent but eddie
of course
was right there got it eddie's guys got
enough range
yep he has long legs for some reason
maybe he likes kicking
yep
oh boy
lost that time that was out of nowhere
right that's been a hallmark of groupies
play style those plasma plays they just
come out of nowhere but here we go it's
set point for callum right now wins this
round and it's over groupies out of here
droopy could do it though all he needs
is this round and then he'll have
another chance three four
oh yeah it's gonna be launched
big damage here early oh my gosh he
wasn't ready
he's testing him in look at that i'm out
of there oh no he couldn't down back
four into screw
not able to do it hey has another
opportunity
oh oh
this is big he does have rage
the lows have not been favorable for him
at all telling you
uh with horung at least right
because horan you know he goes dance and
he's a little bit more predictable uh
but there you have it you know uh
groupie gonna be out of the tournament
at fourth place calum moving on the top